speaking of uh Seven Wonders though and
uh kind of like you know things on your
bucket list we've done a lot in life
right now we've
I you know we've traveled to a lot of
places I'm sure
um do you have anything on your
anti-bucket list the [__] the [__] a
Nancy something that you've done once
and you're like I'm good never doing
that again uh going to France
[Laughter]
specifically Paris I've done it once
actually I'm good actually I agree with
that I think we all agree with that yeah
specifically yeah
going to Paris specifically I do want to
go to France
is actually great yes
how does it feel to be like I wanna to
any French people how does it feel to be
French how does it feel to be for any
French people watching uh to be French
and knowing that Paris has overtaken how
ever like the rest of at least Europe
views you guys well I think I think like
even non-parisian French people can
agree that like yeah Paris kind of
[__] sucks
anti-bucket list honestly [__] Kyoto
dude it is a miserable experience it's
going to Kyoto yeah I mean especially
now that you know the world's back to
normal
Kyoto is what like when people come to
Japan like I want to go see it I'm like
yeah yeah you should you should see it
at least once yeah and never again uh it
is such a miserable time to go like
shoulder to shoulder with people yeah
while you're like climbing up these
stairs it's all sweaty if it's so loud
it's just it's just way too touristy now
right to the point where it's not fun
yeah I think the I think the biggest
problem with Kyoto is that even though
it's supposed to be this very like old
part of Japan traditional part of Japan
where you get to really like you know
immerse yourself in the history of the
country the fact that it is also at the
same time the most touristy spot in the
world is just like that disparity just
like kind of takes the magic out of it
for me yeah you know like again yeah
like I'm sure if it's the first time
coming to Japan Kyoto go for it you know
but once you're there once you're done I
think you're good I don't know I feel
like have you been back to character
since Taurus uh okay I don't want to it
is
yeah yeah I I've seen the pictures I see
the crowds even in places outside of
Kyoto and I'm like no I'm good
especially now I've been three times
since and the outskirts of Kyoto are
still amazing and lovely and really good
but my God the city center is and the
touristy areas are miserable yeah yeah
definitely
um something for me uh I don't know I
don't know why this popped up
skateboarding I think I think I tried it
once
this is a list about going places no no
not going for you it's it's a bucket
list you know the things you want to do
things you've tried once and you're like
I'm never trying that again when did
when did you skateboard you know when
skateboarding like it was when like
[__] Tony Hawks became a thing unlike
everyone in school I tried skateboarding
and that craze became a thing and some
people you know stuck with it and I I
remember trying it once I tried to do an
ollie
um and I was just like my body is just
not built for skateboarding man I you
know sometimes you know some people just
have like a skater energy you know some
people are just like yeah built for this
type of things I I am like the opposite
of that man yeah I mean I did
skateboarding for a little bit when I
was young
um and like I could do like Ollie's and
like you know I I tried to do it you
definitely have skater energy
bro yes I could I could [__] see you
yeah yeah like like I wasn't like great
at it I think I like landed a kickflip
once in my life after eating it 30 times
but like now that I am approaching 30 I
I know my body is just like you don't
have to do this and you're getting older
God yeah I don't want skateboard because
I'm everything will break in my body
yeah exactly that's true as well yeah
but you know I still want to do more
snowboarding
um you did eat a lot of [__] that was
that was very very fun yeah I do want to
do more winter sports uh because I feel
like I didn't grow up with it
anti-bucket list yeah
um I'm trying to think what else is
there
because I usually don't really do things
unless I feel like I'm going to want to
do it again I feel like you had an
answer in Minecon right because you made
you brought this question up was there
something on your mind that you thought
was really funny I don't know I just I I
think I I think I
I can't remember just because I think I
saw like a random Thread about this and
I was like oh that's pretty interesting
I've never heard of the term anti-bucket
list before I think it's yeah they
probably just coined it I think it's
pretty interesting yes
would you do bungee jumping again is
that something you do yeah that was fun
that was fun yeah I love the there was a
sensation when I was bungee jumping
where for like one second it kind of
felt like ah what if I just jumped off a
cliff
uh and you got to have that sensation
for like one second of just complete
like just falling yeah that was really
cool really trippy yeah
you fall faster than you think you would
oh yeah
um you fall so fast gravity is yeah
we're seeing it like POV POV or four
legs
from watching someone else do it and you
see them before and you're like yeah
obviously that makes sense of how fast
they're falling yeah yeah when you're
doing it you jump with a bungee jump
you're like oh my God like this is you
just feel like a rock yeah you you just
immediately plummet and it's such a
weird feeling the like kind of your body
weight just falling yeah it's so fun and
then when you sling up it's really fun
at this moment where I thought I had
like grown out of let's say thrill rides
and uh you know roller coasters and
stuff like that
um and then like I think I mean Sydney
just went on a date like a few months
ago to uh Tokyo dome which kind of have
which kind of has like a little like
theme park area and we were [__]
bored and we were like yeah let's let's
go on the [__] pirate ship you know
you know you know the [__] pirate
ship yeah yeah we were just like get out
let's [__] it let's go on it and just
like be kids again or whatever and we
started off just like you know like kind
of like taking the piss sarcastic they
get to be like whoa whoa we're on a
pirate ship and then when it get when it
gets [__] high I had forgotten the
feeling of like getting butterflies yeah
got a roller coaster and we both came
off with like the biggest [__] pure
smile on our faces it was like one of
the things I've forgotten how much I had
like missed roller coaster and then we
went on like the Tokyo dome roller
coaster as well which I think like has
one of the biggest drops uh in Japan for
roller coaster and it's like
a cabs like I've forgotten the feeling
of just what it almost felt like Free
Falling and just kept going and going
and going and I'm like damn I miss going
to theme parks I want to go to fujiku
now I can't relate man yeah have you
just yeah when did like have you just
never been to roller coasters into
roller coasters never I I think I think
the problem was I went on a roller
coaster I went on like a roller coaster
in in Disney sea when I was like really
young right and that just like scarred
me for Life yeah I think like it I just
don't think yeah I don't know I'm not
it's weird like it's not that I'm not
like a thrill seek or anything it's just
it's very like circumstantial as to what
kind of Thrills I like yeah and just
roller coasters just don't really do it
for me I don't know oh that's it's not
even that like I'm scared of them it's
just like it's not fun yeah I mean like
it's not something on my inside bucket
list go into theme parks that I guess
are actual theme parks are not like
thrilled like Disneyland like Disneyland
I prefer throw parks thrill parks are
like so much better I I just I just
don't understand
for some people it's very magical yeah
but we're better old men so I think I
think I'd rather just go to the movies I
think I'm just too British for that I am
too British dude I just can't when
someone's in like a full costume like I
think we said it's another thing like I
just can't
the thing is they're probably having the
time of their life sometimes or some of
these Disney actors absolutely [__]
love it yeah that's that's I'm happy for
them but for me I just can't
just put myself out although but I had
so much [__] fun in Nintendo land
that like yeah it was cool but I just
wish there was kind of more stuff yeah
well that's quite visually cool to look
that's why I'm excited because they're
making that new uh Donkey Kong area now
all right so I'm going to go back when
that happens but I think yeah just
clearly they should just open up a full
Park and not totally it would crash I
mean the Ghibli Park's opening up as
well and you know that's somewhere I
want to go I think that's what it is
it's like it's not that I don't like
it's gonna they're gonna have a ride
where I mean is disappointed in you yeah
yeah it's gonna be really fun all right
so this is a half troll answer okay go
on then League of Legends what about it
okay you don't want to do it anymore
okay well obviously I've tried it once I
don't want to do it again okay but it's
it's okay obviously haha League fans and
league players but I just think back to
how much time I put into learning a game
like League you know learning the
mechanics and you know you think about
out the barrier of entry about how much
time we have to put in to learn this
game the characters mechanics just to be
competent at it I cannot see myself
doing that ever again for like any other
game yeah just because I don't have that
I kind of wish I could go back and get
into League again yeah so fun when I got
into it yeah such a exciting thing and
it had such a cool premise it was just
really fun yeah because I I think back
and I think like the own like I could
have there is only one point in time I
could have gone into league and it was
the time that I did get into League
because I'll never have that much time
again when I was just in [__]
University had so much spare time and
just I could just grind out games and
just like really learn the game because
now I I just have this thing whenever
whenever I try a game because I'm not
like a [__] streamer so uh I try a
new hot game and by the time I get to
try it out everyone's already [__]
cracked at the game and I [__] suck
yeah yeah
I just get good gone
you're a bronze for a reason actually I
was gold actually I was gold I was wrong
this means absolutely nothing to me did
you have you ever gotten like put like
so many hours into a video game that you
got cracked at it Joey or was it always
single player it was the best game you
ever think you like you're the game
you're best at yeah like multiplayer
like like online multiplayer yeah yeah
uh I was like in high school my friend
really got me into Starcraft
I I I play while everyone else around me
was playing League like me and my
friends were playing Starcraft I got
pretty good at it I did a rank in it or
I don't even remember but because it was
like it was such a it was like a very
condensed short amount of time like it
was there was a period I think for maybe
like like three or four months where I
was playing Star of like every [__]
day off to school yeah and then so so
maybe I got some rank uh up to that
point but it was such a short period of
time and it's a condensed period of time
that I just genuinely don't remember
yeah and uh yeah that's probably my
anti-bocker list too playing Starcraft
because uh they never again probably
never again you do oh I can't remember I
can't imagine you getting into Starcraft
actually I was into it and then at one
point I think I just hit a wall yeah
you're like the most anti-gamer gamer
yeah you just like I just I just don't
like playing I just want to chill and
play Kirby yeah totally it's like I I
just can't play casual like when there's
an option of casual or ranked I'm like
what's the point in playing casual
because I want to
yeah for me it's it's not relaxing to
play casual I'm like there's no Stakes
there's no kind of challenge yeah